(quirky music)
- [Announcer] It's part of the
secret sauce in your Big Mac,
the condiment in your Reuben.
It's creamy yet tangy, zesty,
and named after a breathtaking
part of New York state.
I'm talking about
Thousand Island dressing.
The origin of Thousand Island dressing
traces back to the highest
ranks of American society.
How did it all come to be?
Well, that's where things get interesting.
Two tales lie at the heart of
the Thousand Island dressing dispute.
There is Allen Benas,
former owner of the Thousand Island Inn,
where he claims the dressing
was first served to the public.
And then, there's George
Boldt, a legendary hotelier
whose chef created the dressing
and had it served at his hotels.
We tracked down a George Boldt
expert to explain his story.
- [Shane] George Boldt
was a Prussian immigrant.
He rose to one of the most prominent
hotel men of the nation.
- [Announcer] He also loved to vacation
in the Thousand Islands.
- [Shane] One day, Mr.
Boldt and his wife Louise
were taking a boat ride
on one of the yachts,
and the chef on board
forgot the salad dressing,
so he improvised and created
what became to be known as
Thousand Island dressing.
He loved the dressing so
much, he begins serving it
at the Waldorf Astoria
Hotel in New York City.
- [Announcer] But according
to the other guy, Allen Benas,
it's nothing but hearsay.
- [Allen] The dressing was originated
by the wife of a Clayton fishing
guide named Sophia LaLonde.
She gave the recipe to the
original owners of the hotel,
where it was first served
to the dining public.
After we purchased the
hotel, and going through,
looking at everything,
in the safe was a sheet of
paper with a recipe on it,
and I wasn't sure what it was.
I took it out to our kitchen
staff, and the head cook said,
"It looks to me like a recipe for
"Thousand Islands dressing."
- [Announcer] So, will
we ever learn the truth?
- [Allen] Nothing is more
popular than competing legends.
- [Announcer] Mmm.
Or as delicious.
(quirky music)